باريس اول مدينه في اوروبا تفتح ابوابها
لخدمات تاجيل سكوتر كهربائي في عام 2018
واليوم قد تكون اول من تلغي تصريحه في
2020 اسطوره تريزي الى خفض عدد الشركات
المؤجله الى الثلاثه شركات فقط بعد ما
تسببت عشرات شركات في فوضى بقلب المدينه
وقلنت سرعه كل مركبه الى 20 كيلومترا لكن
المشكله لا تزال قائمه في سبتمبر الماضي
هددت العاصمه الشركات ثلاث بعدم تجديد
تراخيصها التي تنتهي في مارس المقبل اذا
فشلت في تعزيز اجراءات السلامه ومعالجه
استهتار المستاجرين المستاجرون لا يحترمون
في كثير من الاحيان قواعد المرور وغالبا
ما يتركون المركبات على الارض
اليوم تنوي المدينه اجراء تصويت عام يقرر
فيه السكان تجديد تراخيص الشركات الماجره
للسكوتر او حتى حضرها وهكذا نعمه التنقل
الفرديه الحديث المدن تتحول الى نقمه
خلال العام الماضي اشترى الفرنسيون حوالي
900,000 سكوتر كهربائي للاستخدام الشخصي
ما جعل المدينه اكبر سوق في اوروبا
15,000 سكوتر كهربائي هو اسطول الشركات
المؤجره في شوارع باريس ومن المتوقع ان
يصل عدده مستخدم تلك الخدمات الى اكثر من
ثمانيه ملايين في باريس عام
2027 سجلت باريس
337 حادثا مرتبطا بجميع انواع السكوتر
الكهربائي في المركبات المماثله في الاشهر
الثمانيه الاولى من عام 2002 و2020 وهو
ارتفاعه بنحو مئه حادث عن نفس الفتره في
2021 الا شركات المشغله للسكوتر الكهربائي
في فرنسا حققت عائدات جيده جدا خلال العام
الماضي اكبر شركه ناجحه في جاني ارباح
تقدر من مليار ونصف الملياردولار خلال
المشغلون الثلاثه لخدمات تاجير السكوتر في
فرنسا اقترحوا بعض التغييرات لتقنين
الفوضى مثل وضع لوحات تسجيل مركبات حتى
تتمكن الشرطه من رفض المخالفات المروريه
والتحقق من هويه وعمر المستقبل
[موسيقى]
بتاريس نورنا اليوم مراسلت صباح العربيه
زينه عدي زينه يسعد صباحك اهلا بك نورتنا
صباح العربيه
صباح الخير سهام اليوم انا ما كنا نحكي
على موضوع السكوتر بباريس
طيب زين معروف يا زينه انه عاصمه النور من
اكثر العواصم ازدحاما عشان هيك سكان باريس
يستخدمون كثير اودرجه الكهربائيه المفارقه
اليوم مش بس سكان باريس ولكن حتى عمده
باريس يطالب بحضرها ما الذي يزعج فارسي
نعم سهام الحقيقه السكوتر كان لازم من
المفترض يكون ثوره في عالم التنقل كونه
صديق للبيئه لكن للاسف هم بباريس مثل بقيه
العواصم سكوتر عم يسبب مشاكل كبيره لانه
في مخاطر على حياه مستخدمي وايضا على حياه
الاشخاص بالشوارع بالحقيقه الناس ما عم
تلتزم كثير باستخدامه مثلا المصفات ما عم
يلتزموا بوضع السكوتر بواصفاته اعطيكي
مثال خلفي هذا المصاف هذا المشهد استثنائي
صرنا نشاهده بشوارع باريس للاسف من شاهد
السكوتر متواجد بالطرقات بطريقه عشوائيات
هاي بالنسبه للمشاهده بسبب ازعاج ايضا
بالنسبه للشوارع عم يكون السكوتر بسبب
مخاطر على حياه مستخدم عم يسبب حوادث
بالنسبه للسيارات لهيك يعني عمده باريس
فكرت انه هذا الموضوع بدا يتفاقم
يسبب مخاطر على حياه الناس همم لذلك هي
اشجعت انه يكون في استفتاء وقررت انه
هيكون في استفتاء في اثنين من شهر نيسان
همم راح يكون يعرض على الباريسيين همم
الاستفتاء هل انتم مع همم يعني
الاعتماد هذه كوسيله نقل ام لا لذلك يعني
هناك همم اليوم جدل واسع في الشارع
الفرنسيه حول استخدام
السكوتر حجم الاقبال عليه بتحس انه
بالشارع فعلا في كثير عالم صار في حوادث
كمان
الحقيقه يوميا يعني من شاهد يعني ازعاجات
بالطريق على مستوى السيارات وايضا على
المستوى الاشخاص اللي عم يستخدموا السكوتر
انا شخصيا يعني شفت اكثر من مره اشخاص عم
يستخدموا السكوتر حاطين سماعات على قدناهم
ووو يعني حتى زمور السياره اذا كانوا
بمكان مزعج للسياره ما عم يسمعوا او في
مرات يعني يعني بيتقدموا على السيارات
بطريقه مخيفه همم بالنسبه لحياه ايضا ما
عملت ماسك المفروض
10,000 سكوتر في العاصمه طبقه خوفر من
الحضر اجراءات صارمه للبالغين وكذلك تعرف
وتحديد استخدام
سكوتر استخدامهم مره جديده الم تنفع هذه
الاجراءات وهذه القيود
للاسف ما كانت يعني مفيده كليا الاشخاص ما
عم يلتزموا بشكل كامل بذلك حتى يعني
الشركات
قررت انه يعني اقترحت على الحكومه انه
يكون فيه لوحات وارقام لهاي السكوتر لحتى
يصير في متابعه للاشخاص ومحاسبتهم في حاله
في خروقات همم يعني يمكن ان تطبق هذه
الطريقه همم كاجراء جديد لكن يعني نعتقد
بان لن يغير الكثير همم بالنسبه للحكومه
ايضا هناك انقسام همم الامس كان في
تصريحات من وزير النقل همم يعني يتحدث انه
هم مع يعني تنظيم استخدام سكوتر وليس مع
الغاء لانه الحديث اي يمكن للفرنسي يعني
ركوب الاساسيه وين بالتحديد يعني فيها
اماكن سياحيه مثلا مخصص ويستطيع الشخص
ركوب سكوتر فيها
بالنسبه للشوارع هي بالاصل صارت مجهزه
للاشخاص اللي بيتنقلوا عن طريق السكوتر او
حتى البايسكل بس المشكله انه الناس هنا ما
عم يلتزموا بهذا الشيء ااا يعني القيود
يمكن وضع غرامات ماليه ممكن يساعد شويه
بالتزام هاي الاشخاص عمليه ضبط اا ذلك من
عن طريق المراقبه يمكن يساعد همم الالتزام
الاشخاص عن طريق عن طريق لكن بعد انه
الموضوع اكبر من ذلك لانه عم يسبب حوادث
يوميه في منطقه لوهافر مثلا همم في شمال
فرنسا هناك همم يعني احصائيات انه يوميه
في من شخصيه لا ثلاثه اشخاص على المدارس
السنه الماضيه كان في حوادث خطيره وبعض
مميته همم الموضوع عم يتفاقم بفرنسا
والحكومه يعني بدات تفكر باجراءات جديانه
لتغيير الواقع شكرا جزيلا على وجودك معنا
زينه عندي من تاريخ شكرا لك